j'ai été attaqué j'ai littéralement subi
un raid de la part d'un mix m arrête pas
piquée des hannetons mon pote
alors bienvenue à toutes les personnes
qui viennent de découvrir cette chaîne
on va vous faire de la place au mic bon
aujourd'hui je vous propose un nouveau
format je vous en avais parlé dans les
précédentes vidéos on va faire une
expérience ensemble
[Musique]
dans une de mes précédentes vidéos je
vous ai parlé de l'effet mouton chèvre
quand on parle de l'effet mouton chèvre
on parle de l'expérience qu'elle a fait
gertrude uche midler se marient pleurs
wyler je sais pas comment ça se prononce
en 1942 elle avait donc fait une
expérience visant à comprendre le
processus qui peut favoriser ou inhalé
les effets psy les pouvoirs a pas un
psycho logique
cette expérience a beaucoup été
critiqués rayé d'être reproduit tel a
été re critiqué le premier truc c'est
l'expérience vous la décrire en quelques
mots il ya tout un groupe de personnes à
qui on présente des cartes avec cinq
symboles différents dans un ordre
aléatoire et elles doivent deviner dans
quel ordre sont les cartes
ça c'est la première collecte de données
mais il ya une deuxième collecte de
données qui est qu'on différencie les
personnes qui croient au pouvoir si et
les personnes qui ne croient pas aux
pouvoirs psy et on voit quel est le taux
de réussite de chacun où le taux d'échec
de chacun et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant puisque si ceux qui ne
croient pas du tout aux pouvoirs mentaux
pouvoir s'ils ont de très très mauvais
résultats c'est à dire en dessous bien
en dessous de la barre du hasard ça veut
pouvoir dire qu'en réalité ils ont capté
quelque chose et que pour que ça aille
avec leurs croyances et ils ont été à
linverse voyez un petit peu ce que je
parle même si c'est pas très clair mais
dans le protocole de 1942 on ne sait pas
si l'expérimentateur lui-même connaissez
ou pas l'ordre des cartes parce que s'il
le connaissait ça veut dire qu'il a peut
être envoyé des signaux non verbaux qui
aurait été interprété inconsciemment par
l'adversaire d'en face et ouais bon
après les sceptiques critiques ont
toujours que l'argument de la croyance
n'a rien à voir dans le protocole mais
c'est pas très grave
on s'en fiche en fait on veut juste
tester voir les données et voir ce qu'il
ya derrière on va pas chercher à faire
une grande conclusion non plus en tant
que je vous parle des critiques des
sceptiques mais il ya même les critiques
des croyants qu'on pourra aussi qui
disent que le protocole en même temps si
l'expérimentateur de départ croit ou non
au pouvoir si peut-être que ça joue
aussi
alors déjà il ya un truc est cool c'est
que moi je suis complètement neutres
vis-à-vis de salers pas que tu te crois
où tu y crois pas c'est que je n'ai pas
à le témoin d'avis je sais que j'ai pas
de pouvoirs psy je sais que je n'ai
jamais rencontré quelqu'un qui m'a
démontré en avoir mais en plus comme on
va le faire en vidéo je ne risque pas
d'être un expérimentateur réellement ça
va être la caméra qu'il a l'air
je vais donc mettre le protocole en
place dans quelques secondes vous
pouvoir participer je vais collecter les
données de tout le monde et dans la
prochaine vidéo on fera une analyse
précise de ces données j'ai besoin
également de quelqu'un de très fortement
calé en maths c'est à dire que j'ai fait
mes propres calculs j'ai mes propres
résultats mais j'aimerais qu'il soit
valider ou invalider par un professeur
un universitaire je sais pas assez par
un truc très compliqué mais si l'un ou
l'une d'entre vous veux bien me
contacter avec un gros niveau et de
manière à pouvoir le prouver parce que
je veux citer cette personne là aussi
dans le calcul je pense que ça ne lui
prendra que quelques minutes et ça
permettra de vérifier mon calcul à
monter three synthétique
on va donc changer d'environnement on va
utiliser les cartes de nerfs docteur
j'ai passé car cela avec moi mais c'est
pas très grave je vous faire voir les
symboles qu'on retrouve sur ces cartes
là habituellement il ya le cercle
lacroix les vagues le carré et l'étoile
voici les cinq symboles qu'on peut
retrouver habituellement sur les cartes
de rides cercle croit vague carré et toi
j'ai également avec moi cinq bristol
complètement opaque que je vais plié en
deux et je vais dessiner sur chacun de
ces bristol l'un de ses cinq symboles
ensuite je mélangerai tous les bristols
de manière à ne pas savoir moi même
qu'elle bristol à quel symbole depuis je
filmerai ça je vous demanderais vous de
vous concentrer dessus et d'essayer
capter quelque chose s'il ya quelque
chose à capter et de me dire ensuite
dans quel ordre sont les symboles
si vous pensez que en un c'est le cercle
et bien vous vous mettrez cercle si vous
pensez que en 2 c les vagues mais vous
mettrez vague donc certes vagues etc etc
il y aura donc une deuxième information
qu'il faudra me donner c est ce que vous
croyez aux pouvoirs psy par exemple
médium aux rêves prémonitoires à la
télékinésie aux choses qui porte bonheur
ou chose qui porte malheur si vous êtes
croyants dans tout ça ben faudra me le
dire cochez la case le croyant quoi si
au contraire vous êtes sûr et certain
que ça n'existe pas ça c'est certain
pour vous me le dirait aussi et
contrairement à l'expérience de 1942 je
vais aussi collecter une partie neutre
pour les gens qui sont un peu plus comme
moi c'est pas qu'ils y croit ou pas
c'est qu'ils n'ont aucun avis dessus ce
qui est mon cas et après toutes ces
données donc je vais les compiler là
toutes ses dates à là on va faire tout
ce qui est à faire avec et en se fera
l'analyse des résultats sur cette chaîne
alors c'est parti
voilà je mélange les bristols je sais
déjà plus où j'en suis mais je continue
quand même de les mélanger et je reviens
parce que j'étais parti je suis aussi
partie boire un café et gdc pris envers
c'est super pour être le vraiment sûr
sûr sûr que même inconsciemment j'ai
encore opéré quelque chose et que je me
souvienne de quoi que ce soit je termine
de les mélanger maintenant je vais d
notés de 1 à 5
j'ai un peu galéré à les faire tenir ses
pensées que j'ai posé une carte de
visite dessus pour alourdir
ils sont donc numérotées de 1 à 5 il n'y
a qu'une seule fois chacun des symboles
je voulais rappelle le cercle lacroix
les vagues le carré et l'étoile et donc
je vous laisse vous concentrer sur les 5
cartes pour essayer de capter quel
symbole et derrière le vin quel symbole
est derrière le 2 le 3 le 4 et le 5
je vous invite évidemment à mettre pause
pour ça c'est terminé donc retenu est ce
que vous avez ressenti vous cliquez dans
les descriptions il ya un lien vers un
google forme vous allez pouvoir me
mettre les réponses
rappelez vous m'écrivez l'ordre des
symboles qui a d'après vous de 1 à 5 et
dans la description il ya également un
mail pour la personne qui voudrait
m'aider pour valider les calculs
mathématiques que j'ai à faire c'est un
nouveau concept dit moins dans les
commentaires également si ça vous plaît
si c'est le cas j'en prépare et 2 ou 3
ou peut-être quatre dans l'année
expérience sociale tu laisses pause
bleus si tu veux libre as tu nous
regardes jeu collecterait les données au
plus tard vendredi puisque la prochaine
vidéo j'aimerais bien que ce soit celle
ci dans la continuité tout de suite
n'hésitez pas également à faire tourner
la vidéo c'est pas pour la faire tourner
le faire tourner et vous pouvez même
faire juste tourner le petit passage
c'est plus on aura de personnes qui
participeront plus ce sera intéressant
un choix encore en train de créer un
nouveau concept oui je fais que je sache
un milliard ça se passera par les
réseaux sociaux pour les vidéos donc
rajouté moi tout est dans la description
et je voulais remercier tous ceux qui
sont venus me voir jouer à lille on a
fait deux dates archi complet vous avez
également un lien dans la description
assure toutes les dates de tournée là
pour janvier demain je pars à sa galmier
j'enchaîne avec vilar et bienne juste
après je fais brignoles dans le sud et
aix en provence
est ce assez pour janvier et il ya des
dates jusqu'en juin comme d'habitude si
ça vous a plu vous pouvez cliquer et
vous abonner et rendez vous
demain à 17h j'allais dire est annoncée
femis temps là rendez vous très bientôt
dans quelques jours sur la chaîne ciao
et